well president biden says more vaccine
is on the way as mass distribution sites
such as dodger stadium in los angeles
are shut down this weekend
due to lack of supply on friday in the
oval office mr biden met with a
bipartisan group of governors and mayors
who have been pleading for more doses
the nation's daily coronavirus case
count is down
41 percent over the past few weeks and
the number of fully vaccinated americans
now tops 12
million it's helping the centers for
disease control make the case
that schools can be reopened safely they
have unveiled a
new road map showing how it can be done
michael george is outside a public
school here in new york
with all the details michael good
morning
michelle good morning how much success
will have reopening schools
comes down to safety the cdc issued
guidelines on what schools are safe to
reopen and what age group of students
can return to the classroom but
like much of the pandemic response
expect data and science to drive
how when and if a child can attend
school
have you been tested before for starters
the cdc wants children tested repeatedly
and widely across the country as they're
doing in this prototype process
outside of san diego school have you
been tested before
to safely keep children in school the
cdc also has
new color-coded guidelines blue zones
have
low transmission and schools are open
for full in-person learning
yellow is moderate transmission but
those schools can also
stay open orange means substantial
transmission
and schools should switch to hybrid
learning and reduce attendance
and red means middle and high schools
should switch to virtual learning
if there's no regular testing we need to
get our schools
reopened in the state of california for
our youngest
cohorts we can do that safely governors
are under pressure to get more schools
open
only 28 percent of kids have attended
school full-time a harvard survey
reported in january
the biden administration has set a goal
of 51 percent of our kids back in school
in the first 100 days
so minnesota's governor tim walls went
to school
friday seeking directions from educators
to up the numbers
but safety concerns have been raised by
teachers and some have made getting a
vaccine
a prerequisite our preference is to have
our staff vaccinated
cdc's new guidelines do not mandate
vaccinations for teachers
who could get caught up in a quagmire of
continued shortages
los angeles is dodgers stadium for one
shut down when doses ran out
and so far nearly 50 million doses have
been administered
roughly 1.6 million a day but to get to
herd immunity by the end of the summer
cbs news found that number would have to
increase to at least 2 million shots a
day
getting 5 000 approximately 5 000 a week
each week we ask for 50
000 and another safety precaution being
looked at
ventilation schools are being advised to
keep their doors and windows open
if the weather allows for it and upgrade
their ventilation systems
jeff michael thank you very much